[Music]
this is one of london's most
violent boroughs where police and
community relations
have often been strained but here in
croydon
things are changing trust in local
police
has been slowly improving due in no
small part
to the work of community outreach
volunteers like
james and wayne and they're stopped for
when they're not even given a reason
they're deeply worried that the
government's move to pave the way for
more stop and search
will undo all that good work we've been
working tirelessly to build relations
between the
met and the community and it's taken a
long while for us to get to where we are
today and it's going to affect us
massively definitely
do you think that trust is going to go
100
100 i think one of the problems is that
for young people when they're stopped
the trauma that they face
not having even having an explanation as
to why they're being stopped
is a massive issue you know it's one
thing having reasonable grounds which is
quite a vague term anyway
but to them be told we don't even have
to give you a reason we can just stop
you
because of what you look like or because
of who you are it's just a big issue for
us
meeting some of the latest intake of
police officers in surrey
the prime minister defended his plans to
ease restrictions
around stop and search as something that
would actually be positive
for community cohesion i think giving
the police the
uh the the backing that they need in law
to
uh to to stop someone uh to search them
uh to relieve them of a dangerous weapon
i don't think that's a
strong arm tactics i think that's a kind
and a loving thing to do
in manchester rama blagon is still
traumatized by a burglary at her news
agents
earlier this month caught on cctv camera
the two thieves got away with 700 pounds
worth of alcohol
rama says she still hasn't seen a police
officer face to face
since the break-in i just wanted justice
i want
somebody come stand with me and tell me
what i lost it might be in my luck i
lost but i want somebody comes to stand
with me tell me
don't worry this won't happen again as
part of the government's beating crime
plans
greater manchester police will pilot a
project
to ensure burglary victims are visited
by an officer
more widely the plans also include
greater use of electronic tags
for some burglars and thieves on their
release from prison
ordinarily there would be widespread
backing
among rank and file officers for much of
the government's proposals
but a row over pay is the latest issue
that has them less than enthusiastic for
what the police federation says
is essentially a rehash of old
announcements
many of the things being announced by
the prime minister for policing today
we already do an example is named
officers to deal with crime
we already do that we have done for many
many years but what we do need
is a long-term sustainable funding for
policing which we haven't had for
again for many many years as long as
rank and file officers continue their
grievance with the home secretary in
particular
the prime minister's efforts to focus
the public's attention
on a strong law enforcement agenda will
be far from easy
mark white sky news